hey guys I am finally we'd like to make
this official announcement on its great
so the announcement is that there is a
book lady's pantsuits
a dream I've had since I was a young
young child what can I tell you about
this book one most importantly it is
available for pre-order on a website
called great news guidebook calm yeah
Lily's dad book calm - this is not the
real book this is a fake market book
it's an upside down recipe book and said
that's not what this book is about three
what is this book about
great question this book is a guide book
you can read a whole like wonderfully
articulate information paragraph about
it on the website JC's guidebook calm
and I wrote it for you guys because you
guys seem to really like the how to's
and tutorials and that sort of thing
that I try to do I try to teach you
something about life other than what why
falling down is is cool and funny but
this book is for you to help you become
a better adults Grace's guide the art of
pretending to be a grown-up because none
of us really know how to do it but I
tried to figure out some things so it's
it's been a long time coming and this is
mainly the reason why my videos have
been taking so long to upload as of
recently
and why my upper arm strength is so weak
these days because I haven't had time to
exercise I'm holding this camera right
now but it's got some personal stories
that I've never told you guys about that
I think you will like and it's got some
personal issues and things that I've
struggled with in my life that I haven't
really talked to you guys at length
about along with some tips and tricks on
how did handle certain things from how
to get over a hangover
ah to how to do the walk of shame to you
how to hang out by yourself all kinds of
things like that that I think are things
I love to do another one share not that
one hang out by myself
okay I'm sorry that this is not the best
quality video I'm in a car going to the
airport to go back to Los Angeles and so
I just wanted to tell you guys about it
there's a guide book calm it's happening
I've used my hands and type things I did
it on the computer and that myself
thanks college I haven't written long
form stuff in a very long time but I
really enjoyed it and I also got to
reminisce about a lot of memories that I
had repressed seriously for a long time
I hope you enjoy them great this guy
book.com
I went to school for writing never tell
you I think your Tundra is that so it's
real nice to get something out of your
education schools are ghouls layers
be your cans of fun what I don't know I
gotta get off like I'm gonna end this in
the airport yeah